recent heavy rains have Paris on edge
there's significant flooding in the City
of Light and the swollen Sen river is
expected to crest overnight putting
flood response plans to the test
Elaine Cobb is in the French capital
Elaine good morning good morning the
river is still rising and there's
already a lot of flooding in Paris but
the rain has stopped for now however the
Sen is expected to crest overnight
tonight at almost 20 feet that's three
times its normal level
Paris's lower roads and tunnels are
completely flooded and closed the city
center stretch of one of the main
commuter train lines is closed and all
boat traffic on the river has been
banned at the Louvre Museum the basement
galleries are closed and a flood plan
has been implemented the musee d'orsay
and the Aurora museum are also on high
alert in the suburbs people have erected
flood defences around their homes many
are using row boats and barges to get
around but with more rain forecast
tonight and in the coming days The
Weather Service says it will be several
weeks before the floodwaters recede and
the Sun returns to its normal levels
Anthony in Carbon Paris thanks